Congress needs to pass supplemental
funding for Ukraine before they break
for the holiday resources as simple as
that frankly I think it's stunning that
we've gotten to this point in the first
place all Congress Republicans and
Congress as willing to give Putin the
greatest gift he could hope for and
abandon our Global Leadership not just
Ukraine but beyond that I just did a
meeting with the G7 which was one of the
issues we discussed all the European
leaders we are prepared to stay with us
stay with Ukraine and our European
friends are as well who in the United
States are prepared to walk away from
that I tell you I'm not prepared to walk
away and I don't think the American
people are either if Putin takes Ukraine
he won't stop there it's important to
see the long run here he's going to keep
going he's made that pretty clear Putin
attacks a NATO Ally if he keeps going
and then he attacks a NATO Ally where
we've committed as a NATO member that we
defend every inch of NATO territory then
we'll have something that we don't seek
and that we don't have today American
troops fighting Russian troops American
troops fighting Russian troops if he
moves into other parts of NATO make no
mistake today's vote's going to be long
remembered and history's going to judge
harshly those who turn their back on
Freedom's cause we can't let Putin win
say it again we can't let Putin win it's
in our overwhelming National interest
and international interest of all our
friends any disruption and our ability
to supply Ukraine clearly strengthens
Putin's position we've run out of money
to be able to do that in terms of
authorization extreme Republicans are
playing chicken with our national
security holding Ukraine's funding
hostage of their extreme partisan border
policies we walk away now only Bolden
other there would be aggressors so I'm
calling on Congress to do something and
do the right thing to stand with the
people of Ukraine stand against the
tyranny of Putin stand for Freedom
literally stand for Freedom let's get
this done we're the reason Putin has not
totally overrun Ukraine and moved beyond
that you all heard me talk about it
before if in fact we walk away how many
of our European friends are going to
continue to f and know what rates are
they going to continue to fund it this
is too
serious